[Música]
a cadena perpetua más 30 años por
narcotráfico fue condenado por una corte
de nueva york tony hernández el hermano
del actual presidente de honduras juan
orlando hernández quien también a lo
largo del juicio fue salpicado y acusado
de soborno y tráfico de drogas tenemos
los detalles desde la ciudad de nueva
york
después de la salida de dos ministros
tres comandantes de la cúpula militar de
brasil presentaron su dimisión en
protesta contra el presidente ya ir
bolsonaro a quien señalan de intentar
persuadirlos para que se pusieran de su
lado en el escenario político tenemos
reportes desde la ciudad de río de
janeiro
y unos 24 países más la organización
mundial de la salud presentaron una
propuesta para realizar un acuerdo
internacional para el manejo de futuras
pandemias debido a que dichas crisis
superan la capacidad de los organismos
internacionales y de los estados la
propuesta no fue firmada por países como
eeuu rusia china y brasil
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález estamos en vivo desde nuestros
estudios en bogotá en colombia vamos a
comenzar en eeuu en donde un juez de un
tribunal federal de la ciudad de nueva
york sentenció a juan antonio tony
hernández hermano del presidente de
honduras juan orlando hernández a cadena
perpetua más 30 años por narcotráfico
vamos a conocer más detalles de este
caso en el reporte de mamen sala desde
la ciudad de nueva york
si juan antonio también conocido como
tony hernández ha sido condenado y aquí
en la corte federal del distrito sur de
nueva york a 30 años de prisión y aún a
cadena perpetua por cuatro cargos
relacionados con narcotráfico y posesión
de armas además el juez kevin casa el
encargado de esta causa también lo ha
sentenciado al pago de 138 millones y
medio de dólares
el abogado de tony hernández asegura que
este juicio que se celebró ya en octubre
de 2019 correspondió a cuestiones
políticas y tony hernández le ha dicho
al juez que no ha visto respetados sus
derechos la respuesta del juez ha sido
clara los derechos del condenado han
sido respetados en todo momento y además
ha dicho el juez kevin castel que se
trata de una cadena perpetua muy bien
merecida por 12 años relacionados con el
tráfico de drogas ahora la parte del
condenado tiene la opción de apelar la
sentencia a algo que se espera que hagan
próximamente los abogados
de tony hernández eso sí el juez le ha
dicho que en el tiempo en prisión
aproveché para reflexionar sobre lo que
ha hecho y a ver si puede hacer algo
bueno por su por su país y por su
familia recordemos que el juicio de la
sentencia que se ha leído hoy tuvo lugar
ya en octubre del 2019 y la lectura de
esta sentencia se ha [__] en varias
ocasiones cuando por fin hoy la hemos
podido conocer esos 30 años de prisión
más cadena perpetua obviamente este
segundo esta segunda condena anula a la
primera
nos vamos ahora hasta brasil tres
comandantes de la cúpula militar
presentaron su dimisión esto un día
después de que el presidente de ese país
de aire bolsonaro decidiera cesar a seis
altos cargos ministeriales entre ellos
el ministro de defensa y el de
relaciones exteriores desde la ciudad de
río de janeiro valeria saccone nos da
más detalles en el siguiente reporte
las últimas noticias serían que los tres
comandantes de las fuerzas armadas
habrían renunciado antes de que el nuevo
ministro de defensa pidiese su relevo la
razón serían las profundas discordancias
con el presidente jair bolsonaro hay que
recordar que ayer el ministro de defensa
que salió fernando acevedo lo dijo
diciendo que intentó durante todo su
mandato que en las fuerzas armadas
fuesen una institución de estado y no de
gobierno de hecho a lo largo de esos dos
años ha servido intentó mantenerse
alejado de la deriva autoritaria de la
deriva de derecha del presidente y jair
bolsonaro y participó es crítico también
cuando él bolsonaro participó en las
manifestaciones a favor del cierre del
tribunal supremo- hay que decir que él
bolsonaro ha intentado politizar las
fuerzas armadas parece dicen los
bastidores que habría pedido tanto al
ministro de defensa que ha salido como
altos generales que apoyasen al gobierno
con
textos en sus redes sociales la
respuesta fue negativa la principal
piedra en el zapato de bolsonaro era el
jefe del comandante jefe del ejército
exxon puyol que varias veces dijo que
los militares no deberían estar en el
gobierno y que además estaba en
desacuerdo con la gestión de la pandemia
por parte de bolsonaro y seguimos
hablando de brasil porque este país en
registró un nuevo récord diario de
muertes por cuenta del cob y 19 en
espacio de 24 horas 3 mil 780 personas
perdieron la vida según reportan las
autoridades sanitarias de ese país
la nación suramericana contabiliza hasta
el día de hoy más de 12 millones 573 mil
casos de contagio un total de 313 mil
866 personas han perdido la vida desde
que comenzó la pandemia mientras que más
de 18 millones de dosis de vacunas de
han sido inoculadas en la población esto
según cifras de la universidad johns
hopkins y agua world in data
es extremadamente improbable que el
virus del cobi 19 haya sido desarrollado
en un laboratorio del que podría haber
escapado a esa conclusión llegó el
equipo de estudio de funcionarios del
gobierno chino y también de la
organización mundial de la salud que
intentaban determinar el origen del
nuevo coronavirus en medio del
desconcierto mundial por esta conclusión
del informe los científicos afirmaron
que tuvieron problemas para acceder a
ciertos datos que permitirían confirmar
el origen por lo que no descartan otro
tipo de teorías como por ejemplo que
haya sido transmitido de un animal a los
humanos
como se esperaba no aportó demasiados
datos nuevos el estudio conjunto de la
organización mundial de la salud china
sobre los orígenes del coronavirus
concluyó que probablemente el virus se
había transmitido de murciélagos a
humanos a través de otro animal los
autores de los informes no descartaron
otras teorías this is on live
éste es sólo el primer comienzo solo
hemos arañado la superficie de este
conjunto muy complejo de estudios que
deben realizarse y hemos señalado muchos
estudios adicionales que deberían
realizarse a partir de ahora fraguan el
equipo concluyó que si bien no era
imposible una fuga en un laboratorio de
buján era la hipótesis menos probable un
hallazgo sobre el cual la o ms planteó
interrogantes el director de la entidad
indicó que el equipo había tenido
dificultades para acceder a algunos
datos y que se requería más
investigación estados unidos y sus
aliados hicieron eco en una declaración
conjunta
lamentaron que el estudio se retrasó
significativamente y no tuvo acceso a
datos originales completos el equipo de
la o ms pasó cuatro semanas en luján
enero y febrero más de un año después de
que aparecieran los primeros casos la
investigación se retrasó debido a que
china restringió el acceso al
laboratorio y al mercado de alimentos
donde se identificaron los primeros
contagios en humanos el equipo concluyó
que el rol que había tenido el mercado
era incierto también juzgó que la teoría
de beijing que plantea que el virus no
se originó en china sino que se importó
en alimentos congelados es muy poco
probable los gobernantes de 24 países
entre ellos chile y costa rica y también
la unión europea como bloque junto al
director de la oms se instalaron a
elaborar un tratado internacional sobre
pandemias para enfrentar crisis
similares a la que tenemos actualmente
que podrían presentarse nuevamente en el
futuro las grandes potencias como eeuu
china rusia y también brasil se
abstuvieron de firmar este borrador del
acuerdo que busca un compromiso
colectivo para la preparación conjunta
para combatir pandemias similares a
nivel político dado que ningún organismo
multilateral o tampoco los estados
pueden hacer frente a este tipo similar
de amenazas
para conversar y analizar este tema
hemos invitado al señor francisco
becerra él es ex subdirector de la
organización panamericana de la salud
también es consultor en salud pública no
se atiende hasta ahora desde la ciudad
de mexico señor vence a regresos por
estar con nosotros y comienzo por
preguntarle más detalles de esta
iniciativa de 24 países y del lado ms
que propone exactamente
buenos aires santiago mucho gusto mire
lo que se trata es tener un tratado
internacional que permita que los países
puedan atender de manera unificada un
problema como la pandemia que estamos
viviendo que el acce de medicamentos
tratamientos equipo y vacunas sea lo más
equitativo y lo más
probable que todos los países tengan
acceso a lo mismo sin embargo tenemos
ciertas dificultades por la palabra
tratado un tratado por lo general tiene
que pasar a través de los congresos
tiene que ser ratificado y es ahí donde
pudiera haber alguna cuestión vinculante
mientras se atrae a través de los
mecanismos normales de la visión mundial
de la salud que son propuestos en la
asamblea mundial de la salud cada mayo
pues no necesariamente son vinculantes
en cuanto a que no hay sanciones para
que se justifique o para qué
si lo que se tiene que hacer son así
como deseables que los países firman y
tenemos el caso claro del reglamento
sanitario internacional que pocos países
siguen cuando hay algún problema en los
niveles tierra esta emergencia sanitaria
a nivel mundial que falencias dejó en
evidencia por parte de los organismos
internacionales también de los estados y
de la cooperación mundial más allá de la
capacidad económica
primero que la relación mundial de la
salud no tiene ningún proceso de poner
sanciones o de obligar a los países a
que hagan lo que tienen que hacer dentro
del marco del reglamento sanitario
internacional segundo los países tienen
una visión de seguridad nacional y
nacionalista antes que atender los
programas globales y pues desde una
perspectiva de país eso es normal y lo
otro es las grandes dificultades que hay
en cuanto a que la falta de inversión de
los países censal en salud hemos visto
los problemas que esto ha causado
-soy problemas e incluso en países ricos
que no han podido servir un frente
adecuado a la pandemia señor becerra que
lectura si usted de la posición que
tiene rusia china eeuu y también brasil
de no ser parte de este tratado de esta
propuesta internacional
primero porque los dos tienen su propia
iniciativa de global health security que
es promovida por el cdc a nivel global
para tratar precisamente de compensar
todas las falencias que tiene el
reglamento sanitario internacional yo
creo que esta parte ellos piensan que
pues a pudiera ser la mejor manera de
fortalecer a los estados para poder
atender este tipo de problemas segundo
de que esta es la visión nacionalista de
qué
y mientras yo pueda contener estos
problemas al interior de mi país pues ya
podría atender los problemas señor
francisco becerra ex subdirector de la
organización panamericana de la salud y
consultor en salud pública muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
aquí en france 24 vamos a cambiar de
tema indignación en méxico por un nuevo
caso de abuso de la policía en esta
oportunidad terminó con la muerte de
victorias ha lanzado una ciudadana
salvadoreña en la ciudad de tulum en el
estado de quintana roo la fiscalía
general de méxico anunció que impondrá
acciones penales contra los cuatro
oficiales de policía implicados en este
caso mientras que varias organizaciones
defensoras de los derechos humanos
exigen a las autoridades mexicanas que
este caso no quede impune marina sardina
nos cuenta más
la brutalidad policial también es
sistemática en méjico donde los abusos
de las fuerzas de seguridad están en la
cotidianidad la indignación ha sacudido
el país después de la violenta muerte de
la refugiada salvadoreña victoria
salazar bajo custodia policial de
brutalidad policial es es una tendencia
latinoamericana de las fuerzas de
seguridad
las mujeres sentimos que no nos protegen
la muerte de victoria se une a las de
alexander martínez y giovanni lópez a
manos de las fuerzas del orden mexicanas
el año pasado en noviembre de 2020 la
policía empleó munición real contra una
manifestación feminista en cancún el
pasado 8 de marzo reprimen las marchas
por el día internacional de la mujer
cobras el lacrimógenos y balas de goma
los datos muestran el estructural
deterioro de las instituciones de
seguridad en el país siete de cada diez
personas detenidas sufrieron amenazas o
agresiones por las autoridades durante
su arrestos según una encuesta del
instituto nacional de estadística y
geografía realizada en 2016 una
situación agravada para las mujeres que
frecuentemente sufren abusos sexuales
las mexicanas reclaman al estado una
mejor protección frente a las múltiples
violencias
más de 140 mujeres han sido asesinadas
en lo que va de año la brutalidad
policial implica el uso excesivo de la
fuerza física y otro tipo de ataques que
resultan innecesarios para contener
ciertas acciones esto en ocasiones puede
llevar a la muerte tal aspecto debe ser
sancionado
urgen medidas efectivas que lo eviten a
futuro los críticos afirman que la
solución del abuso por parte de los
policías mexicanos no pasa por
militarizar la seguridad pública sino
por la construcción de cuerpos
policiales cuyo objetivo sea la
prevención y no la represión así como la
mejora de las condiciones laborales y la
aplicación de leyes efectivas para
evitar la impunidad de quienes cometen
los abusos
y avanza en la ciudad de minneapolis en
eeuu el juicio contra el ex policía
derecho bin acusado de la muerte del
ciudadano afroamericano george floyd en
la jornada de hoy rindieron declaración
varios de los testigos que presenciaron
la detención y la muerte de floyd quien
estaba bajo custodia policial por
solicitud de la fiscalía los testigos
dieron detalles de como el entonces
oficial chauvín detuvo a floyd lo redujo
por la fuerza y puso su rodilla por más
de nueve minutos en el cuello para
impedir que se moviera los testigos
confirmaron lo que evidencian también
varios vídeos aficionados en los que
floyd pide al oficial que retire su
rodilla del cuello porque le impedía
respirar
posteriormente sucumbió
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
en france 24 más información en france
24 punto com en las redes sociales y en
la app sica con nuestra programación
buenas noches para todos
[Música]